President Trump now says he wants to
reopen the country for business by
Easter even as health officials warned
the corona virus pandemic will continue
to worsen in the u.s. Easter as you know
is just 18 days away that's very close
from now Paula Reid reports from the
White House Easter is our timeline what
a great timeline that would be President
Trump says he wants to see packed Easter
services in just over two weeks I just
thought it was a beautiful time to be a
beautiful time a beautiful timeline was
based on a certain level of weeks from
the time we started and it happened to
arrive actually we were thinking in
terms of sooner but dr. Anthony foutch
II who returned to the coronavirus
briefing stage yesterday says not so
fast you can look at a date but you got
to be very flexible and on it on it
literally day-by-day and week-by-week
basis medical experts have spent weeks
warning Americans against crowded spaces
and aren't willing to loosen those
restrictions just yet no one is gonna
want to tone down things where you see
what's going on in a place like New York
City so I think people might get the
misinterpretation you're just gonna lift
everything up and even somebody's going
like that I mean that that's not gonna
happen it's gonna be looking at the data
the president's comments came just hours
after New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
said that his state could see the corona
virus infections hit a peak in two to
three weeks and as other states are
battling rising trends she says I don't
think he's listening to the science I
think that he is you know operating you
know he's looking at the stock market
the president's aggressive timeline
receives pushback from lawmakers on both
sides of the aisle Republican
congresswoman Liz Cheney tweeted there
will be no normally functioning economy
if our hospitals are overwhelmed that's
Paula Reed reporting for